this video is brought to you by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform
where entrepreneurs can easily create
and customize their own personal or
professional website more on Squarespace
later in the video so hello and welcome
to another episode of biographics I'm
your interim host Carol small and today
we're talking about Edward III England's
real-life King Arthur and yes I've
listened to the feedback
um I I got rid of the mics I can touch
my desk as much as possible using a lav
mic now so hopefully you don't get any
of that awkward feedback I've been um
hearing from people but also I've got a
haircut no matter what like I did
um but I've got a very big head you have
to understand anyway let's get to it
thank you
in the Middle Ages people had developed
an idea of what they thought a good King
should be while wisdom good judgment and
honorable conduct were all considered
important or considered to be most
important as a king's ability to lead
his troops on the battlefield it is no
coincidence then that most of the era's
greatest Kings also rank among its best
military commanders of all these there
was perhaps none better than England's
King Edward III and it was pointing out
like over here in Jolly Old England at
King Edward is the nickname for potatoes
I know what a legacy that is certainly
no king of his era was more respected or
feared by his enemies than Edward he
routinely performed Feats on the field
of battle considered almost miraculous
by a contemporarist in the process
evolving the art of warfare Itself by
utilizing the latest Innovations in the
technology and tactics designed to hurt
people his Wars would help shape the
course of European history for centuries
afterwards in his achievements in peace
were no less significant although much
less interesting to talk about in a
YouTube series in fact some historians
are called Edward the father of the
English Nation so cheers dad I suppose
because thanks to him England will begin
to transform from a provincial Backwater
into a continental Powerhouse that all
the courts of Europe will be forced to
respect on the English themselves now to
establish a unique national identity and
distinct culture I don't even know how
to responds
I can say English food is good that you
call that beans on sauce is toxic about
me in the comments
Edward Above All Things Considered
himself to be a knight Bound by a code
of chivalry that was considered
extremely important in its time strange
it may seem towards today he modeled
himself off the mythical figure of King
Arthur and just like Arthur Edward's
live scene to be a series of Adventures
from start to finish each one more
exciting than the last and by the time
his last adventure finally ended his
country and the world itself would never
be the same again
[Music]
perhaps the most remarkable thing about
the story of Edward III is just how
close he came to never really ruling at
all he was born November 13 1312 in
Windsor Castle 25 miles west of Wonder
he was born in the purple the eldest son
of King Edward II making him heir to the
throne of England from the moment he was
born however his Royal inheritance will
be threatened at young age by the
limitations of his father Edward II who
was considered altogether a weak King
lazy and indecisive and prone to placing
too much executive power in the hands of
his favorites first Piers gavistan who
was murdered by a political enemies six
months before Prince Edward was born and
then Hugh dispenser the younger which is
like you know a hell of a name and his
father the Earl of Winchester these
favorites alienated and angered all the
members of the courts by amassing
increasing political power and wealth
into their own hands often at the
expense of the other Nobles Civil War
was the inevitable result Queen Isabella
Prince Edward's mother was a particular
enemy of the dispensers and in 1325 she
separated from her husband the king
taking up residence in support of her
brother the king of France when she
began an affair with Roger Mortimer an
English Baron who fought against the
dispensers was now living in exile over
in France then she tricks her husband
into sending their son to France as well
and then refused to return him back to
England instead she and Mortimer use the
Dowry they receive from betrothing the
prince to Philippa of henault to build
an army of mercenaries in order to
invade England and dispose King Edward
and the dispensers Royal Authority
completely collapsed in the wake of
Isabella and maltima's invasion in
September 1326 as all of Edward's many
enemies flocked to their Banner less
than two months after landing they had
captured the king in his hated favorites
who were all
brutally executed in typical British
fashion Edward himself was in prison
forced by Mortimer to abdicate in favor
of his son in January 1327. one story
posits that Edward was killed by having
and I quote a red hot fire poker short
right off his Royal backside this is
just to be highly unlikely by actual
historians it's a fun story though the
prince meanwhile was crowned King Edward
III at age 14. his Regency was dominated
by Mortimer now the title The Earl of
March who began to accumulate vast
amounts of land and wealth for himself
sparking more discontent among the
Nobles Edward at times felt like little
more than a figurehead and it seemed
unlike that Mortimer was going to
willingly relinquish power to him when
he reached his majority there were even
rumors that Isabella was pregnant with
mortimer's child and that he was making
plans to seize the throne for himself
[Music]
October 19th 1330 A Band of knights led
by William Montague a close friend of
Edward snuck into Nottingham Castle and
staged a coup deter resting Mortimer
after a brief fight the plan had been
orchestrated by the king who'd finally
had enough of his mother's lover
Mortimer was executed for treason while
Isabella whom the King was somewhat
attached escape with only a short period
of house arrest Edward was now King in
his own right and after a few years of
consolidating power at home he set out
to prove himself on the international
stage beginning with his Northern
neighbor England and Scotland have been
fighting each other for almost 40 years
stemming from Edward's grandfather's
attempts to seize the crown of Scotland
for himself in 1296. in 1327 however
Mortimer and Isabella had agreed to a
treaty with the Scots which renounced
all English claims on Scotland a treaty
Edward vehemently disagreed with when a
rival claimant David II for the Scottish
Throne Edward baliel saw his help King
Edward decided the time was right
through new hostilities and continue
with the long-standing initiation of
attacking Scottish in 1333 Edward laid
Siege to impulsive Border Town of
Berwick his purpose was not just to
capture the town but straw the Scottish
Army into battle where he could defeat
them it worked because the story should
always write Rowdy for a fight I mean I
mean historically like I'm half Scottish
I can say that right
right anyway like they attacked him in
the Battle of Haledon Hill and they were
decisively defeated the young King's
first military Victory Holly Don Hill is
noted as being the first major
demonstration of the power of a weapon
that will come to define the English
army the Longbow a lesson Ed would
remember in later engagements bullion
was set up as a client King of Scotland
having exceeded large amounts of
territory to Edward but this would not
bring peace to Scotland and believe it
would not sit on the throne for long
foreign the major problem was the old
alliance between Scotland and France
which had been renewed in 1326 by the
French King as long as the Scots could
count on French support if they were
attacked Edward would never be able to
truly assert authority over Scotland
since he'd always have to contend with
French attacks on his lands in gascony
as well as raids and a possible invasion
of England itself The Logical result of
this was war with France beginning in
1337. the traditional stories of the
Hundred Years War which fun fact didn't
last for 100 years between England and
France began when King Edward challenged
Philip VI over who should hold the title
King of France but the truth was the two
countries were already at War when
Edward first made the claim in 1340.
Philippe had invaded English held
gascony attempting to eliminate the
English Monarch possession of lands in
France and Edward had responded by
attention to build an alliance against
Philip with the low countries and the
Holy Roman Empire one of the most
important allies Edward wanted to win
over was Flanders which was economically
dependent on English wall Imports to
fuel their textile trade but Flanders
owed its allegiance to the kingdom of
France and if it rebelled Against The
Sovereign Lord it could be placed on the
Internet by the pope cutting it off from
the Catholic church and by extension God
himself however if Edward claimed to be
the rightful King of France Flanders
could pay homage to him instead and be
Allied to England without risking the
wrath of an angry deity so that's just
what Edward did declaring Philip to be
the usurper and quartering the arms of
England and France together on his coat
of arms he's unlikely that he ever
seriously considered attempting to seize
the throne of France for himself it
would have been nearly impossible for
one man to rule both Kingdoms at the
same time effectively but still he sent
a message and that message was screw
France
[Music]
reports have been flooding in of an easy
and affordable solution to help you
create an amazing personal or
professional website these reports are
of course talking about Squarespace the
sponsor of today's video it doesn't
matter if you're completely new to web
design or a Big Brand looking to stand
out Squarespace is the best platform for
you isn't that right Joe that's right
Annie It's interface is so easy to use
and there are so many many ways to
customize everything whether you want to
start blogging create a business
portfolio or set up an online shop
Squarespace is there for you yeah
hey
squarespaces Next Generation website
design system fluid engine means
creating your own website has never been
so easy
with their drag and drop technology you
can add anything from text to images and
video to links and newsletters and all
of it is infinitely customizable on both
desktop and on mobile
simply marvelous
look at all these visitors to your
website wouldn't it be great to keep all
of them updated with vital announcements
or upcoming sales then try new email
campaigns buy Squarespace just give your
followers or customers the option to
join your mailing list and boom look at
how easy it is to cover all of your
clientele so are you saying the two
credits careful analysis of data and
analytics with your success indeed
understanding your online traffic where
your visitors and sales come from is the
best way to figure out the most
effective strategies for improvement you
can analyze what your most effective
channels are and maximize your
marketability based on your most popular
content or top keywords Squarespace
allows you to do all of that and more
fascinating it's like I always say
analytics are like a wounded salmon all
they need is some raspberries to take
bite
what
[Music]
I don't have much time so listen closely
head to squarespace.com forward slash
biographics and use the code biographics
to get 10 off on your first purchase of
a website or domain did you get that
okay
I'm going in
thank you
[Music]
once every motivations Edward's
Declaration was a shock to everyone from
the pope all the way down to the English
Parliament King Philip in particular was
enraged how dare this Petty king who
ruled half of an insignificant Island on
the outskirts of Europe
yep challenge him the rule or the most
powerful Kingdom in all of Christendom
France the pope wasn't impressed either
but that was hardly a surprise the
papacy itself at the time was not based
in Rome but in Avignon in southern West
France the office was held by a series
of Frenchmen throughout the time and all
the Pope's close advisors had close ties
the French Crown the first major battle
between King Edward and the French occur
not on land but at Sea when a large
French naval fleet commanded by the
Admiral and Constable of France blocked
the entrance to the zwine Estuary of the
English Channel near the Flemish town of
stewies they were attempting to stop
Edward's own much smaller flee which was
transporting his army to the town of
Bruges in order to Stage an attack on
France itself European countries of this
period had few purpose-built warships
the bulk of both fleets was made up from
converted Merchant vessels known as cogs
which have been requisitioned from
Traders despite being to put it
diplomatically heavily outnumbered and
outgunned Edward boldly attacked the
French ships which had chained
themselves together in three battle
lines to block the approach this would
prove to be the quite literal on doing
as they were unable to maneuver when
their battle began allowing the English
to pick them apart piece by piece once
again the superiority of the Longbow was
demonstrated as the English were able to
pick off the French Sailors at a
distance from which they could not
retaliate the result was a massacre
between 16 and 20 000 Frenchmen died
many of them drowned while trying to
escape the English Onslaught the Marshal
of France was beheaded the Constable
hanged both in Revenge for prior French
atrocities commit against English
Sailors and because again it was English
cost at the time to screw France
whenever possible despite the stunning
Victory Edwards campaign of 1340 award
and in Failure because the king ran out
of what Cicero called the sinews of War
AKA money war was an expensive
undertaking in the Middle Ages and
Edward had borrowed heavily to pay for
his army to bribe his allies and now he
had no more gold to finance The Invasion
frustrated he returned to England
literally sneaking out in the middle of
the night to escape his creditors Vine
one day to return to finish what he'd
started
[Music]
Edward spent the next few years at home
wrangling with Parliament over financial
matters and most importantly the only
action in the war was a limited English
intervention in an ongoing succession
battle over the dukedum of Brittany in
Northwestern France as well as almost
continual border skirmishes with
Scotland finally in 1346 the King was
ready to try again this time he had a
well-supplied army of 15 000 men a
mandate from Parliament to finish the
war that came with a guarantee of
Taxation to fund it and a determination
to prove to Philip and all of Europe
this was a king to be reckoned with
Edward's Army London Normandy in July
and March with impunity to the land of
his ancestors William the Conqueror
towns up become famous centuries later
as World War II battlefields were looted
and burned by the English and these are
all French words I'm not sure how to
pronounce I'm going to try my best here
cherborg karantan Saint Lo St Mary Elise
and Kane well at least he tried the
inhabitants of these towns were
slaughtered in their hundreds the laws
of chivalry not applying to the
commoners this was a deliberate strategy
by Edward known as chevoshe a score
Earth rate of the path of Destruction
some 20 miles wide in the Army's wake it
was designed to showcase the French
King's weakness to humiliate him and
provoke him into a battle with English
forces but Philip was not stupid enough
to leave the forks of Rowan waiting for
the main French army to come up from
gascony to attack Edward with
overwhelming Force he would not move
even when the English came within two
miles of Paris itself prompting panic in
the streets of the French Capital but
Edward wasn't interested in besieging
Paris instead turning North her winslink
caught with a second Army of Flemish
allies finally Philip pursued him
destroying the bridges on both the
scenes some rivers to try and trap
Edward for the English forced across the
rivers anyway having crossed the whole
of northern France Edward now learned
that his Flemish allies had given up and
gone home so there'd be no
reinforcements we decided to stand and
fight anyway because the French
and the English they fight a lot it's
like cats and dogs
the position that the French army found
the English in on August 26th of being
carefully selected by Edward he was on a
sloping Hill his flanks anchored by the
village of Wadi court on his left and
the large town of Creasy on his right he
had also dug trenches in front of his
lines to disrupt attacking Horsemen all
of his men at arms would fight on faults
which appeared to the mounted French
Knights to be a distinct disadvantage he
was well known that infantry Lions could
not stand against the cavalry charge of
armored Knights for centuries this has
been the most devastating heavy weapon
in medieval arsenals or so they thought
Philip decided to attack that very same
afternoon rather than wait and give his
army a chance to rest which would have
been far more practical and no one's
really quite sure why he did this say
for the fact that the English were there
and he was spoiling for a fight first
would sack were the Vanguard of
mercenary archers from Genoa hoping to
soften up the English lines ahead of a
French charge but they were the first to
come within range of the deadliest
weapon in the English Arsenal the
longbow it's believed that each English
Archer could fire between 6 and 10
arrows per minute with an effective
accuracy of up to 300 meters this is
significantly better than the genoese
crossbows they were driven off within
minutes and many were killed by the
French themselves who accused them of
cowardice and treachery now the French
Knights charge will they immediately run
into problems it just rained so the
ground was muddy and they were charging
uphill into a storm of deadly Arrow fire
and they were hampered by The Trenches
the English had done the horses in
particular unprotected from the arrows
that felt like snow or coin to one
chronicler suffered terribly many of
them collapsed throwing their Riders who
were crushed off suffocated to death by
the time the charge reached the English
lines it retained little of its initial
momentum was repelled with heavy losses
that day the French army made some 15
separate charges each time they were
driven back not only by the hail storm
of arrows but the confusing and
terrifying sound
Cannon Edward had fully embraced the
martial potential of gunpowder and this
battle was one of the first in history
to feature the deployment of cannons
outside of a Siege King Philip had two
horses shot from under him and was
nearly killed when an arrow hit him in
the jaw finally he was compelled to
leave the field in his wake with the
ruined flower of French chivalry one
afternoon of a 1500 French and Allied
Nobles had been killed the dead included
but was not limited to the king of
bohemia the Duke of Lorraine nine
princes ten counts and two Bishops and
no one bothered to count the number of
common soldiers that died but it's
believed to be astronomical for the time
in the Battle of Creasy Edward made
History For the First Time One Army had
defeated another primarily through the
use of projectile Weaponry rather than
hand-to-hand combat noble-born Knights
extensively trained and expensively
armored for war had been slaughtered at
the hands of farmers and Yeoman Sons
Edward had defeated the best Army in all
of Europe leaving the rest of the
continent no choice but to take him and
thus England much more seriously from
then on out Edward would follow up his
success buying teaching the city of
Calais on the channel Coast Philip was
powerless to prevent Edward from seizing
the most well-forced White City in all
of northern France obtaining its
surrender after a seize that ended in
August 1347. the English would hold
Calais for the next 200 years using as a
forward operating base for attacks on
France this was part of a strategy that
Edward had once described stating the
best way to avoid the inconvenience of
war is to pursue it away from one's own
country meaning that the best way to
keep English safe from Attack was to
keep the conflict within France as our
territory the war well down the
following year however as all of Europe
grappled with a new altogether more
terrifying anime the Black Death as much
as 40 of the population of Southern
England died of the plague in 1348 alone
including two of the Kings and children
King Philip himself would die in 1350
bringing the great rivalry between him
and Edward to an ignominious end
foreign
largely withdrew from physically
participating campaigns after creasing
probably deciding he had nothing left to
prove to anybody instead he focused
attention on domestic matters and taking
plenty of time to relax and enjoy
himself and was caught was known for his
extravagance vast Sons were spent on
food clothing jewelry and of course the
King's favorite pastime hunting falconry
and jousting tournaments his court was
known apparently for its sexual
adventurousness while Edward himself
appears to have been entirely devoured
to his Queen Philippa admittedly though
it's unlikely would have had the time or
energy for all the Pursuits considering
his wife bore him 12 children his eldest
son Edward known history as the black
prince of Wales and known best to me for
his cameo in A Knight's Tale starring
Keith Ledger would carry on the English
military tradition winning an arguably
more important Victory than Creasy in
1356 and the Battle of poitias not only
did Prince Edward win but the king of
France John II was taken prisoner in the
process being brought to England and
presented to his father the French
monarch joined the King of Scotland
David II who had been imprisoned by the
English
capture the Battle of Neville's cross
while Edward was a color King Edward was
Victorious on all fronts he decides
would be in his enemies was respected by
all of Europe and loved by his people
but now he would remake England into his
version of Camelot embarking upon great
building projects including extensive
renovation a Windsor Castle itself still
used today as a royal residence he would
also employ some of the finest artists
and Poets of his era to create new and
beautiful works with buildings few of
which sadly survived to this day this
Renaissance include the elevation of the
English language itself which sadly I am
not continuing the tradition of because
I speak with the common tongue at the
beginning of his Reign the language of
the nobility was French with official
documents written in Latin now Edward
became the first king to dictate that
the court and parliamentary proceedings
as well should be conducted in English
the language that Mouse with subjects
spoke to this end he employed Jeffrey
Chaucer also known for his cameo in A
Knight's Tale where he's played by Paul
Bettany and in history he's known one of
the greatest writers of English and
within decades English would supplant
French as the commonly spoken language
by everybody in the country from the
King thing on down I have to mention a
night's Tale in this regard once again I
apologize for this if you've not seen it
although you probably should it's really
great have an amazing character moment
which I think just typifies like English
sentiment towards the French where
um Heath Ledger and his crew were
arguing with some French um no balls in
a bar where like the French decided to
insult the English by saying what
everybody knows that the pope is French
to which um ethics Mark Addy
um brought AKA Robert Baratheon goes
okay the pope is French but Jesus is
English it's just yes I just that light
always slave me Edward was a great lover
of innovation he paid for the first
mechanical clocks we built in England
including one set up at the Bell sower
at the palace of Westminster which
chined out on the hour every hour and is
described as the original Big Ben he
built what was also probably the first
bathroom in England South both hot and
cold running water which was piked in
from a neighboring chamber where it was
prepared he also established the order
of the Garter his answer to King
Arthur's Knights of the Round Table in
1348 but perhaps his most enduring
Legacy was his Embrace of Saint George's
patron saint so devoted was he to this
Christian Master his armies carried
Saint George's now iconic red and white
cross as one of their principal battle
standards this would become the flag of
England itself eventually and is still
incorporated into the modern day flag of
the United Kingdom if anyone doesn't
know the the modern day flag of the
United Kingdom and combines the flags of
England Scotland and Northern Ireland
and unfortunately there's no dragon on
there from the Welsh flag and there have
been calls in recent years do that
because it would be awesome
time is the enemy of all men as the old
saying goes and so it was for King
Edward but last year's Reign we're not
happy ones in 1360 concluded the Treaty
of Brittany with the French in which he
promised to announce his claim to the
French throne in exchange for large
territorial concessions he also secured
a massive Ransom of King John II for all
intents and purposes he'd won the war
between 1364 John died and with much of
the ransom still on paved the new King
Charles V was not prepared to accept his
predecessor's failings in the loss of
part of his inheritance and so the war
continued this time it was the English
who on the defensive and Edward could
only watch helplessly as most of what he
gained was once again lost Edward had
now outlived his glory years and he was
an old man by medieval standards his
health began to fail him and he was no
longer able to take to the field to
defend his realm worse still he lived
through the almost constant grief of
watching his friends relatives and loved
ones die before he did his companions
from his younger days including almost
all of the founding members of the order
of the Garter pre-deceisted so his
mother brother both his sisters and
eight of his own children his beloved
wife Philippa died 1369 and Edward took
a Mishra Alice Perez who spent much of
her time enriching herself and her
friends and the King's expense the final
blow came in 1376 when his first born
son and Heir the black prince died after
years of debilitating illness rendered
him as infirm as his father in April
1377 the daughtering Old King who
reigned for some 50 years at this point
knighted his two ten-year-old grandsons
the future kings Richard II and Harry IV
in the Saint George's day ceremony the
two cousins would fight each other over
the crown 20 years later so we set into
motion the events of the War of the
Roses in the 15th century
for any like pop culture nerds out there
is one of The Inspirations for Game of
Thrones The War of the Roses between um
house York and House Lancaster
um Starks Lannisters north south two
months later Edward finally died of a
stroke and was buried in an elaborate
ceremony next to his Queen at
Westminster Abbott in his wake he left
England forever changed by his kingship
England and France would fight each
other on and off for over a century as a
tradition with the French finally
emerging victorious in 1453. the marks
of England and Great Britain would keep
the title king queen of France in their
names until 1802. a 450-year time span
that would see the two Nations contest
each other for dominance on battlefields
all over the world it is a legacy that
one of the greatest Warrior Kings in
British history would probably
appreciate so thank you for tuning in to
this episode of biographics there's no
sort of stars I've been your interim
host Carl Smallwood this video was based
on an original article by Ben Edelman
links to our socials can be found below
and yeah thank you for tuning in if
you've enjoyed this video like and you
liked it you can like it if you want to
comment on something I said you can
leave a comment if you want to see more
like this you can subscribe if you want
to see more of me I'm not sure why you
would but I also host the sister
channels for um the top tens Network top
tens and Geographics again links to
which you can find below and also my own
channels fact feed and Wiki weekends
otherwise I hope everyone enjoyed and
learned something today and as always
have the day you all deserve
[Music]
also watch a knight's tail it's a really
good film take your Heath Ledger markade
and Paul batine what more could you want
cheers